welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead dead City season one it
starts with Maggie who's out on a
scouting Mission looking at the Big
Apple New York City specifically the
island of Manhattan once home to
millions of people now home to millions
of zombies Maggie realizes she's gonna
need help so she tracks down her best
friend of me Negan yes remember when
Negan was a villain he killed her
husband Glenn brutally with a baseball
bat right in front of her obviously
Maggie wanted to kill him but in the
final season of The Walking Dead she and
Negan were forced to work together to
survive Maggie of course could never
forgive him but she accepts that he's a
goodish guy now and so she explains that
her son Herschel was kidnapped by the
new bad guy on Manhattan called the
croat because he's Croatian and the
reason she's come to Negan for help is
because they know each other the crow
act used to be in negan's gang the
saviors now at the moment Negan has a
kid of his own he's taken care of this
random teenager he's adopted they got
like a Joel and Deli from the last of
using going but wait a sec at the end of
the walking dead Negan had a pregnant
wife she and their kid are conspicuously
absent he doesn't explain what happened
to him yet so for now Negan agrees to
help Maggie if she takes this new kid
into her community and so once again
Maggie and Negan are forced to work
together off on another adventure team
nagagi or magigan either way they find a
boat and set sail to the island of
Manhattan dead City the big city is a
nice change of pace from the Walking
Dead's normal locations of the woods it
comes with its own dangers like zombies
falling off the skyscrapers and giant
bags of cockroaches but there's another
problem because Negan is a wanted man
for killing a couple new Babylon
Marshalls new Babylon is apparently the
big community in the New York area and
Marshall pearly Armstrong is willing to
do whatever it takes to get his man
probably follows him here they have a
big fight in the laundromat but they get
away now they run into crazy New York
hobo lady who teaches them how to get
around the city using their system of
zip lines all right she leads them back
to her friends of New York survivors
including tommaso who's like gay I'm
from New York and Amaya who's like hey
I'm from New York yeah but pretty soon
the croats gang shows up the barazi and
it's a big old fight Negan captures one
and to scare them off he goes back into
his old Negan Persona puts on a big show
cracking jokes and slitting throats oh
now this whole time Maggie and Negan
have been bonding and he's been trying
to explain how he's always been kind of
a good dude that just put on the villain
Persona when he had to he never wanted
to do it again but you know sometimes
you gotta meanwhile the crow act has
captured pearly and shows him that they
got a good thing going on here
apparently this guy's like a chemical
engineer and knows how to use the
methane from decomposing zombies to make
electricity he does put pearly through
the zombie Gladiator trials but pearly's
a badass he takes out these zombies with
his shoe so they make a plan to sneak
into the barazi headquarters kill the
croat and rescue Herschel but when our
group sneaks in no one's there then the
Croatian music starts a play in oh it
was a trap yes he's learned all the
zombies in here right now uh our games
fighting to survive all the extras get
eaten meanwhile Negan has Tracked Down
The Crow at himself now they did not
part on good terms the croat's a bad
dude he was negan's torturer but one day
he tortured and killed someone that
nikin told him not to so Negan tried to
kill him and shot his ear off but now
that they're face to face the croat
doesn't want revenge he's happy to see
him Negan my brother turns out he's a
huge Negan Fanboy he built his whole
gang here in the savior's image and
wants Negan to rejoin him and lead him
as a show of good faith he goes to kill
the Marshall Hunter Negan but this guy
holds on and Negan chooses to save him
this might have been a bad choice
because even now pearly's like hands up
I'm bringing you in but they gotta work
together running from some zombies they
go through a weird postmodern zombie art
installation and eventually Negan
explains that the marshals he killed
were real bad cops that robbed and beat
up his wife and turns out she and their
kid are still alive yeah now that
negan's a wanted man he sent him on
ahead to Missouri or something meanwhile
Maggie and the New Yorkers are escaping
through the sewers but when tommaso
finds a couple oxygen tanks Maggie
realizes he set them up yeah he realized
there was no beat in the crow at so he
sacrificed the rest of his friends to
protect him and Amaya which turns out
not mattering anyway because like five
seconds later they both get eaten and
now Maggie faces a terrifying new type
of zombie that's like a couple zombies
smooshed together oh gross but she
manages to take out all its heads one by
one meanwhile negan's adopted daughter
Jenny he's been hanging out at Maggie's
new community up here the brick house
but she has a hard time fitting in
because she doesn't talk anymore since
she was scarred after her parents were
killed and she really loves Negan he
became like a really good dad figure to
her so she runs away from safety and
follows him to New York negan's like yo
kid the whole reason I'm doing this is
to get you a safe place to live but
she's not leaving in fact for the first
time she's gonna say something but Negan
stops her she's not safe here and the
only way he can get her to leave is by
making her hate him by telling the truth
because the person who killed her father
was Negan yes he was one of those bad
Marshals so now she hates Negan and goes
back with pearly to Maggie's brick house
and so Maggie and neaton have to try
Plan B which is just the two of them go
to rescue Herschel but this whole time
Maggie has been a little suspicious and
now Negan finally figures it out she
didn't need Negan to help rescue
Herschel she needed Negan to trade him
for Herschel so Negan makes a run for it
but Maggie catches up to him and these
two have a Maggie Negan fight suspended
over the pit of Walkers oh Maggie stabs
him then Negan kicks her off ouch but
now Negan surrenders he's like look mags
I thought we had kind of become friends
but I guess not maybe I deserve it do
what you got to do so it's the crow that
shows up Maggie takes Negan prisoner and
we see this was their deal all along
she's finally rescued her son Herschel
but it's not really a happy reunion
Herschel was a cute little kid but he's
grown into just a brat of a teenager now
why does the crow act want Negan so much
well we go to see his boss who's got a
lair in an old theater she is the Dharma
a weird theater lady who's trying to
unite all of New York under one Empire
but if she's the director she needs a
leading man to take the spotlight and
when the croat told her about Negan
she's like oh that's my guy negan's like
look lady I don't really do that anymore
but to motivate him she shows him
herschel's pinky toe that she cut off
like yeah we can always go back for more
if you don't help so negan's gotta stay
on Manhattan to play his character of
the big villain and Maggie realizes this
ain't over there's another villain above
the croat plus Marshall pearly back in
new Babylon covered for Negan told him
he's dead but when his boss hears about
this zombie methane electricity she's
sending him back there to go get that
and so the adventure on Manhattan is not
done yet where will this go in dead City
season 2. if you like this recap hit
that subscribe button for more of the
best Recaps of TV and movies
foreign